and speaking of which finally new rules
someone needs to explain to me when did
the NYPD start suffering from PMS
seriously if our deal with the police is
we have to constantly reassure them how
much we love them or else they throw a
tantrum we're not supporting them we're
dating them because right now honey
I mean officer I'm confused
yes you have a tough dirty job but you
volunteered for it it's like a
proctologist coming home every night and
saying I can't believe I have to look at
[ __ ] all day
now let me be clear I new support the
police and I understand that their job
is looking at [ __ ] all day but
something outrageous has been going on
in the Big Apple the last couple of
weeks as New York's whiniest have been
staging a virtual work stoppage to teach
Mayor Bill DeBlasio a lesson for not
saying he loves them enough citations
for traffic violations public drinking
and urination are all down 94 percent
yes okay you ruined the next joke for me
I'm sorry
drug arrests are down 84% parking
violations down 92% so it's a great time
to visit New York get drunk stoned and
urinate out the window of your double
parked car also Emma Stone is in cabaret
a delightful now of course the cops were
already furious with the mayor for not
endorsing their novel crime prevention
tactic of choking random citizens to
death but purposefully not doing your
job turning their back on him at
funerals I mean what did de Blasio do
get caught in a video with Ice Cube
singing [ __ ] the police no no as the
father of a black son he just said a
very true thing he said there are many
families in this city who asked every
night is my child safe and not just from
crime and violence but from the very
people they want to have faith in as
their protectors I know I know
how dare he spread a myth that is only
corroborated by every single black
person ever but you know you can't stop
doing your job just because you feel
unloved one New York detective said cops
have feelings too
another complain there are people out
there who don't like us yes cuz you
choke them to death
probably not you specifically and I'm
sure not most cops but there is a
problem which is when did the police
become infallible no matter what they do
they always say it was by-the-book put
six slugs into an unarmed man from the
seat of your car by the book strangle a
handcuffed guy to death by the book kill
a twelve-year-old who had a toy gun by
the book maybe they need to get a new
book
who wrote this book anyway George
Zimmerman
I mean when was the last time you heard
a cop's yeah we got that one wrong sorry
it never happens it could be a baby
holding a rattle and they'd be like well
the baby did point the rattle out the
officer and crawl toward him in a
menacing way babies have to understand
when the officer tells you to drop the
binky drop the [ __ ] binky which you
know what is actually not such a big
stretch the president of the cleveland
police union said killing the
twelve-year-old with the toy gun was
justified
it was the police union in New York that
encouraged the work stoppage it's the
union that's fighting the reasonable
idea that cops should wear cameras this
is why Americans hate unions now it's
why Republicans have been able to make
taking on the unions an applause line
because union [ __ ] that people see
on TV made it easy for them to make it
about crybabies and entitlement which is
a shame because with a record wealth gap
we need unions now more than ever when
America when America had a thriving
middle class one in three workers had a
union now it's one in ten it's not hard
to do the math except in this country
because we can't fire teachers